whosoever be he worthy shall haveth  apart whatever man it's a trail it is  much more than that my friend if I lift  it to a get to the last guard yes of  course I will be fair but firmly cruel  get back  I'm even pulling are you on my team just  represent pull alright let's go smoke  out  nothing oh no that's not a question I  need answered  the handles imprinted whosoever is  carrying Thor's fingerprints is I think  the literal translation yes that's a  very interesting theory I have a simpler  one you're all not worthy  how could you be worthy you're all  puppets tangled in strings  it's the end the end of the path I  started us on nothing lasts forever  there are no strings on me  you